i know there's a complicated history
with dustin diamond but he's been so
public about really wanting to be a part
of it
he's good for america greece you'll
always be first lead
you're a producer on the show what is it
gonna take to maybe see him in season
two
if there's a season two i'm one of a
whole group of great producers and
dustin listen i don't know if we're
discussing
but i just don't know yet it depends on
the story lines and how they play out
and all of that but i wish dustin
nothing but the best
i just haven't seen him for a lot of
years but i do wish him the best he was
always kind to me
so there's a little invitation out there
that's waiting we'll see wow
i don't know what to say well good we
don't have time to hear it
we definitely hear about screech like
where there's jokes about what he's
doing now and there's some easter eggs
about
his life or whatever if you look closely
in the show
you know it was a hard thing this this
season it's just
10 episodes and in addition to trying to
find places
to use the original cast some felt more
organic because they're already parents
of the students it's like
you really want to spend the majority of
your time with these
new characters and invest in them and
really care about what happens to them
because if you don't
it's a one-off it can't be a show that
goes on for season
after season i you know as a fan of the
show sure i'd love to see screech and i
i would be open to it if there was
another season he does not make camu in
this one
i have a kardashian coming at lunch who
rob shut up
he's still in their family one of the
most exciting parts of this show were
all the little easter eggs that you
sprinkled in and all the amazingly
topical
celebrity references and pop culture
references can you walk me through a few
that are your favorite or that were
um i don't know the most fun to inject
into this series
in terms of easter eggs for the original
show like it
that was one of the most fun things
about this like really looking at
spots where you could be like oh i bet
we can get the exact
guitar that zach had when he was in zack
attack or
you know i bet we can put slater's
wrestling singlet up on his wall and
it's always there or
their diplomas save the day they like
things you probably
won't even everyone won't even notice or
the song that's playing at the max is
the song that zach put subliminal
messages in in the one epic code so
it was really fun for me to have this
extra job that i haven't had on other
shows
to kind of find ways to weave those
things in and
you know obviously franco was incredibly
helpful with that because sometimes i'd
be like i need a prop and he can be like
it's in my app
because franco worked on the original
show he would just be like oh i have a
i have a jacket from malibu wow god so
you sourced a lot of original props and
mementos
some yes yeah there's a there's a photo
of kelly that
um yeah it was literally that was fun
yeah yeah
so that's in kelly and zach's bedroom
we'll see but
yeah there were a lot of times i was
like let me check my attic i might have
[Music]
that
you